sie sind gigantisch
technologischer meisterwerke die täler
und gewässer verspannen
eisenbahnbrücken bilden das rückgrat
vieler schienennetze überall auf der
welt personen und güterzüge überqueren
sie jeden tag
[Musik]
hunderte tonnen gewicht dann über sie
hinweg eine riesige dauerbelastung
deshalb müssen sie ständig unter
schwierigen bedingungen gewartet werden
man könnte auf dem kabel ausrutschen und
sich trotz sicherungen verletzt
viele stehen den schwer zugänglichen
gelände oftmals in gegenden mit extremen
klimatischen bedingungen
[Musik]
im winter erreichen die temperaturen
minus 20 grad und im sommer bis zu 55
der bau ist eine herausforderung
ferngezündet und boom der ganze berg ist
abgehoben
ein multi millionen projekt das nie
endet
und manchmal ist der preis noch weitaus
höher
während der bauarbeiten kamen viele
menschen ums leben
aber wenn der job geschafft ist und
menschen und waren sicher ans ziel
kommen dann haben sich aufwand und
risiko gelohnt
das ist die first bridge und es wird
immer nur diese eine geben
[Musik]
wie entstehen die riesigen konstruktion
und welchen herausforderungen müssen
sich die wartungs teams stellen
dies sind die spektakulärsten
eisenbahnbrücken der welt
[Musik]
eindrucksvoll
einzigartig
und schwindelerregend hoch
moderne eisenbahnbrücken sind echte
hightech wunder aber ohne die simpleren
konstruktionen aus der anfangszeit des
zugverkehrs während sie undenkbar
dies köln britt im nordosten englands
ist eine der ersten brücken für dampf
betriebene eisenbahn der erste zug
passiert die brücke 1825
je nach strecke und nutzung werden
eisenbahnbrücken den verschiedenen
bauweisen gefertigt
anfangs werden viele brücken mit
fachwerk trägern aus stahl konstruiert
auch die ziegelbauweise mit mehrfach
bögen ist verbreitet
heute tragen meist balken und
bogenbrücken die immer schwereren
schnelleren züge
[Musik]
ein viadukt über vier etagen
mehr als 150 jahre alt und immer noch im
dienst
die göltzschtalbrücke die größte
ziegelstein brücke der welt sie ist über
500 meter lang ihre größte spannweite
beträgt 30 meter
die göltzschtalbrücke liegt in sachsen
rund 90 kilometer südlich von leipzig
bis zu 100 züge überqueren die brücke
jeden tag die konstruktion hält den
tonnen schweren lasten immer noch stammt
aber nur weil sie permanent saniert wird
ulrich schäfer und marcus fischer sind
fast täglich auf der göltzschtalbrücke
unterwegs
[Musik]
heute steht die kontrolle des mauerwerks
an den wind und wetter setzten den
ziegelsteinen stark zu
[Musik]
meistens ist es ja eigentlich wasser was
die pri geschädigt
also das ist durch die die fahrbahn war
eine von oben ein dringend denn die
undicht ist wenn die abdichtung nicht
passt oder sei es dass es durch durch
starkregen seitlich ins mauerwerk trifft
wohl mögliche meisterleistung so prägen
und herzustellen und
auf dem boden bleibt soweit möglich
unser schmuckstück
mit der sogenannten katze einer speziell
für die brücke angefertigten befahl
anlage machen sich die männer an die
arbeit
ihre mission kaputte ziegel finden und
austauschen
immer mit dabei
wasser
mertel
[Musik]
ersatz ziegel
22 millionen ziegelsteine hunderte bögen
und gewölbe
falk erkennt die brücke wie kein zweiter
er hat schon als junge mit seinem
großvater die gleise kontrolliert und
später an ihr das maurerhandwerk erlernt
heute überwacht er als ingenieur ihren
erhalt
es gab es damals noch nicht man könnte
das freie reisen
mit feuer reisen in solch einen druck
nicht beugen im rahmen der gründung fand
man neben wenn ich leben haben kann ich
titel morgen
allerdings hat damals noch niemand
geahnt welche geschwindigkeiten und
lasten die brücke zukünftig aushalten
muss
umso wichtiger heute feste und intakte
ziegel im ausgeklügelten fachwerk
konstrukt über das bis zu 80 meter über
dem grund züge hinwegdonnern
hier wirst
die beiden techniker sind nun weit über
der talsohle die arbeit in dieser höhe
sorgt immer wieder für leichtes
herzrasen egal wie oft die männer schon
gehoben waren
doch einige
beunruhigender als die höhe ist das was
der ingenieur hier oben vorfindet
durch risse im mauerwerk ist
feuchtigkeit in die wand eingedrungen
wenn das wasser im winter gefriert und
das mauerwerk sprengt könnte die brücke
instabil werden
das hole geräusch beim klopfen kein
gutes zeichen
sie braucht ist hoch
dass sie diese auf andere weise und die
führung eine lösung sind das müsste er
wird alle sterben
mit kleinen nachbesserungen ist es hier
nicht getan aber für umfangreiche
reparaturen muss ein gerüst her dabei
wurde die brücke erst vor wenigen jahren
umfassend modernisiert
aber sie muss für den schienenverkehr
erhalten werden
[Musik]
in die brücke kommt man sich eigentlich
nur verlieben weil die zeigt ein server
als die alte handwerkskunst
uns mit der zeit wurde sie gewählt wurde
mit welch einfachen mitteln ich will ein
monumentales bauwerk entstand
das zweitwichtigste material für den bau
der brücke ist holz es stammt aus dem
einst dicht bewaldeten umland
[Musik]
aus holzbalken entstehen die so
genannten leer gerüste
hilfskonstruktionen auf welche die
rundbögen gemauert werden ist der bogen
fertig wird das leere gerüst entfernt
der bau ist ein kraftakt bis zu 1700
menschen arbeiten gleichzeitig an der
brücke
31 sterben bei unfällen bei der
fertigstellung im jahr 1851 ist sie die
höchste eisenbahnbrücke der welt des
wurden arbeitsplätze geschaffen mit ein
paar eisen bonns präsident ein frisch
war wuchs die industrie sprunghaft
unterfangen so auch wieder am lohn und
brot
und deshalb hat man auch um die
eisenbahn so gekämpft mit dem bau der
göltzschtalbrücke wird ein wichtiger
handelsweg zwischen nord- und
süddeutschland fertig gestellt und eine
ganze region an den welthandel
angeschlossen
die substanz der brücke ist eigentlich
gut damit das so bleibt müssen markus
fischer und sein kollege jeden ziegel
überprüft
ein schwachpunkt sind die eckpfeiler
zwischen den böden denn sie sind der
witterung ungeschützt ausgesetzt
[Musik]
vor allem die verbindung zwischen
plattform und mauerwerk muss regelmäßig
instand gesetzt werden
hier zerstörte frost immer wieder die
obersten ziegel reihen die techniker
geben sich im kampf gegen die witterung
aber nicht geschlagen die ersatz ziegel
die sie verwenden sind keine standard
ware die single hier sind speziell das
ein speziell für diese brücke
angefertigt und zwar die sind in
sogenannten kürze format dargestellt
länger als die heutigen normalform
einige ziegel
speziell
abgestimmt die handgriffe beim
ausbessern haben sich in über 150 jahren
kaum verändert
die maurer der göltzschtalbrücke haben
damals äußerst präzise gearbeitet
die männer heute versuchen es ihnen
gleichzutun
das war in beiden titeln
als kleines bank
die techniker sind für heute fertig die
brücke hat zehn neue ziegel bekommen und
wird noch viele züge über skills stahl
prix das faszinierende an der hier ist
eben vor 160 jahren gebaut und die nimmt
die ganzen kräfte und den ganzen verkehr
mindestens 160 jahren kommen derzeit
nicht
[Musik]
die göltzschtalbrücke eine ikone aus
einer anderen zeit die den bogen in die
gegenwart spannt
[Musik]
in schottland steht ein weiteres moment
der ingenieurskunst ein roter riese aus
stahl
[Musik]
50.000 tonnen der metalllegierung wurden
bei seinem bau verarbeitet die fonds
bridge gilt als die erste brücke der
welt die vollständig aus stahl besteht
sieben jahre lang schuften über 5000
arbeiter um die eisenbahnbrücke
fertigzustellen bis heute muss sie
täglich gewartet werden
sie ist rund zweieinhalb kilometer lang
ihre größte spannweite misst 520 meter
die fritz liegt zwischen edinburgh und
aberdeen
[Musik]
mehr als 200 züge rauschen täglich über
die gleise damit alles glatt läuft sind
jeden tag mehrere teams mit erwartungen
beschäftigt
[Musik]
kämmerin michael und sam and eight
bereiten sich auf ihren einsatz vor eine
der größten brücken wartungs pruß
weltweit arbeitet das ganze jahr über
daran die brücke zu erhalten
die beiden industriekletterer sind seit
über sechs jahren dabei
jeden morgen starten sie mit dem
vorgeschriebenen sicherheitscheck
rettungswesten an
für die reparaturen in 50 metern höhe
gelten strengste sicherheitsauflagen
nicht nur für die arbeiter keine
gegenstände dürfen auf den boden oder
die gleise fallen für kate ist die höhe
teil des jobs
ich habe respekt vor der höhe aber keine
angst mein job ist es darauf zu achten
dass alle das machen wofür sie
ausgebildet worden
vor fünf jahren ist hier ein brücken
arbeiter tödlich verunglückt die männer
gehen kein risiko ein
dass da ist unsere notfalltasche ich
drücke die daumen dass wir sie nicht
brauchen
zum rettungssatz gehört eine spezielle
hub vorrichtung im ernstfall können sich
die arbeiter eigenständig hochziehen
oder verletzte bergen die kletterer
machen sich auf den weg zum südturm
hier entsteht eine neue arbeitsplattform
alle zwei wochen müssen sie die träger
auf ihre festigkeit überprüfen keine
leichte sache in schwindelerregender
höhe und die höhe ist nicht das einzige
problem mit dem sie konfrontiert sind
die größte herausforderung ist das
wetter wir sind sie direkt über dem kopf
deswegen wird es oft sehr sehr windig
die brücke führt über den verkauf der in
die nordsee mündet hier weht der wind
schon mal mit 145 kilometern pro stunde
zwei absahner werden am turm an der
südseite arbeiten
die arbeiter melden ihren einsatz bei
der küstenwache an damit sie im notfall
schnell hilfe leisten kann
meine frau will meistens lieber nicht
wissen was ich so mache sie macht sich
sonst total verrückt aber
sie hat mich schon oft arbeiten sehen
und weiß dass ich dabei immer auch passe
zumindest vertraut sie darauf dass ich
das mache und jeden abend nach hause
komme
die komplexe bauweise der brücke
erschwert die wartungsarbeiten
um das gerüst zu checken seinen sich
tate und michael ab dabei muss jeder
handgriff sitzen denn ein fehler kann
schnell zu brenzligen situationen führen
es gibt bestimmt brücken an denen man
entspannter arbeiten kann das und eben
unsere täglichen herausforderungen
die starken winde haben es auch den
arbeitern beim bau der brücke schwer
gemacht auf arbeitsschutz achtet ende
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts kaum jemand
73 männer sterben während der sieben
jahre langen bauarbeiten
chefingenieur john andrew kennt die
schattenseite der brücke
viele menschen haben während der
bauphase ihr leben verloren der fokus
lag damals auf funktionalität und nicht
auf sicherheit
deswegen sind sehr sehr viele gestorben
von den arbeitern die an der fünf briten
kommen ist der jüngste gerade mal 14
jahre alt und
nicht nur der bau von eisenbahnbrücken
es damals extrem gefährlich
anfänglich soll search die vor sprit
entwerfen als vorbild nimmt er die fans
oft eisenbahnbrücke doch die stürzt bei
einem sturm ein und reißt einen voll
besetzten zug in den fluss 75 menschen
sterben nach der katastrophe wollen
andere architekten alles besser und
sicherer machen
konnte es nicht mit dem wind und dem
gewicht der züge aufnehmen bei der forst
bridge wurde wert darauf gelegt dass sie
sicher und robust ist und das ist sie
auch sie sieht massiv aus aber sie
erfüllt genau den zweck für den sie
gebaut wird
es wird immer nur eine form geben
die ingenieure benjamin becker und john
fowler wollen an der bahn brechen die
idee verwirklichen die erste ausleger
brücke die komplett aus stahl gefertigt
ist
so massiv dass ein unglücklicher bei der
tate britain möglich scheint das projekt
ist für architekten konstrukteure munter
arbeiter eine riesige herausforderung
zweieinhalb kilometer brücke werden von
sechseinhalb millionen nieten
zusammengehalten
von den fundamenten aus ragen drei
mächtige fachwerk pfeiler über 100 meter
hoch
[Musik]
sechs ausleger 2 1 hänge träger und zwei
viadukte verbinden den stahlkoloss
das prinzip hinter der ausleger brücke
die hauptlast in der mitte wird über die
unter gurte und diagonalen streben auf
pfeiler und fundamente verteilt die
pfeiler und fachwerk träger werden
zuerst errichtet anschließend werden sie
mit 1 hänge trägern verbunden nur an
diesen punkten ist die brücke beweglich
[Musik]
in luftiger höhe kämpfen tate und
michael noch immer mit dem wind die
industriekletterer prüfen heute ein neu
errichtetes gerüst das für bauarbeiten
an der brücke gebraucht wird
durch die starken vibrationen der züge
lösen sich regelmäßig schrauben
wenn tate die nicht wieder fest zieht
kann es zu schweren unfällen kommen
auch wenn die kletterer einen
gefährlichen job haben was anderes kommt
für sie nicht in frage
die brücke hier ist eine ikone ein
fantastisches bauwerk ich arbeite sehr
gern hier und gerade die
herausforderungen machen spaß
noch ein paar muttern fest ziehen und
das gerüst ist wieder stabil
ein brand
zeit für den letzten anstrengenden
aufstieg des tages dann heißt es
feierabend für die beiden männer
die fritz wurde 2015 zum unesco
weltkulturerbe ernannt für die
industriekletterer hat die brücke ihren
ganz eigenen reiz kein tag ist wie der
andere
es macht echt spaß
[Musik]
nach dem erfolgreichen einsatz meldet
sich kate bei der küstenwache ab
die absage am südturm sind fertig
[Musik]
bis 2012 wurde die brücke aufwendig
restauriert
mehr als 1500 leute waren an den
arbeiten beteiligt kostenpunkt rund 130
millionen pfund
[Musik]
seit über 125 jahren trotzt wind und
feuchtigkeit sie ist eine wichtige
verkehrsader
die forth bridge in schottland
[Musik]
portugal hier steht einer der längsten
hängebrücken der welt auf der züge und
autos fahren ein doppeldecker mit einer
höhe von 190 metern die portugiesin
cabrio in lissabon auf deutsch die
brücke des fünfundzwanzigster april ihre
längste spannweite misst über einen
kilometer bei einer gesamtlänge von
knapp 2300 metern die einheimischen
nennen sie schlicht ponte sie führt über
den flusstälern
160 züge befehlen sie täglich der bau
erfolgte in etappen zuerst die straßen
dann die zugverbindung die panther muss
intensiv gewartet werden sie wird tag
und nacht überwacht
[Musik]
die einsatzzentrale an der nordseite der
brücke antonio reyes und luis diaz
machen sich für ihren einsatz bereit ein
job der es in sich hat
die anfang ist immer ein bisschen
schwierig wegen der höhe der windböen
und weil die kabel so schwingen
[Musik]
die elektriker müssen bei vollem betrieb
ran
eine brückensperrung undenkbar bis zu
7000 fahrzeuge die stunde
150000 täglich die potter ist eine der
wichtigsten nord süd verbindungen in
portugal
alle drei monate müssen die männer auf
die beiden hauptpfeiler klettern über
die steilen halte kabel
das war bisher nur wenige male hoben er
arbeitet jetzt an einem jahr auf der
brücke jetzt gilt es die 120 meter bis
zur spitze auf dem schmalen kabel zu
balancieren
dabei sind die us und will was durch ein
seilsystem gesichert sie müssen immer
mindestens auf einer seite eingehakt
sein
[Musik]
an der porte arbeiten techniker parallel
an mehreren stellen eine etage tiefer
kümmern sich ingenieur pedro ab egal und
sein team um die belastung durch den
schienenverkehr
die portale gibt es zwar schon seit 1966
durch die eisenbahnlinie ging erst 33
jahre später in betrieb die männer
checken heute das eisenbahn peg
das zusätzliche gewicht der personen-
und güterzüge macht eine regelmäßige
inspektion notwendig ist die bahnstrecke
in den 50er jahren geplant wird richtet
niemand mit dem heutigen
verkehrsaufkommen
aber eines ist schon damals klar eine so
lange brücke braucht ein sicheres
fundament
und die ponte hat das tiefste fundament
der welt fast 80 meter unter der
wasseroberfläche
zwei pfeiler im tv tragen die
konstruktion der fluss ist nicht nur
sehr tief er hat auch eine starke
strömung
ingenieur pedro ag ist seit jahren für
die wartung der brücke verantwortlich er
weiß um die schwierigkeiten die es beim
bau gab
es war eine große herausforderung
die technologie war total neu die
entfernungen um die es hier geht sowas
gab es bisher nicht in europa
für das fundament haben wir zuerst
einzelne segmente gebaut die wir
versenkten
dann haben wir immer wieder neue von
oben drauf gesetzt bis wir am grund
waren
über 300 menschen sind vier monate mit
dem bau der fundamente beschäftigt in
zellen bauweise versenken sie große
stahlzylinder die in betonblöcke gefasst
sind
bei diesem verfahren werden die
hohlräume um die röhren herum mit beton
gefüllt
durch das gewicht sinkt das element bis
kurz unter die wasseroberfläche
dann kommt das nächste identische
segment obendrauf
das ganze wiederholt sich bis am ende
alle hohlräume mit beton gefüllt sind
und die konstruktion im flussbett
gründet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber die tiefe des fundaments war noch
nicht mal die größte sorge damals denn
das fundament wurde in einem bereich
errichtet in dem seismische aktivitäten
nachgewiesen worden das hat vielen
menschen sorge bereitet die das große
erdbeben von 1755
noch in erinnerung hatten
der tum ist in lissabon selbst an seiner
schmalsten stelle immer noch 2 km
deshalb kommt nur eine hängebrücke in
frage das material für die halter kabel
wird auf riesigen rollen geliefert
jedes kabel setzt sich aus über 11.000
dünnen stahl treten zusammen die per
seil system immer wieder über den tisch
geschickt werden hin und her bis der
benötigte durchmesser von knapp 60
zentimetern erreicht ist mit einer
spannweite von etwas über einem
kilometer ist die potter bei ihrer
fertigstellung die längste hängebrücke
europas
30 jahre nach der eröffnung der straße
beginnt man mit dem ausbau der
eisenbahnlinie direkt darunter die
arbeiten dauern drei jahre
seit der erweiterung ist der
auflagepunkte fahrbahn auf den pfeilern
eine der kritischen stellen ingenieure
checkt und der träger genug spiel hat
die fahrbahn liegt nämlich auf einem
sogenannten gleitlager
falls das lager blockiert kann es
passieren dass der pfeiler schaden nimmt
falls etwas bremst und die fahrbahn sich
nicht bewegen kann dann könnte etwas
verbiegen oder sogar irgendwann brechen
welche belastungen der träger aushalten
muss zeigt sich wenn ein zug die brücke
überquerte die fahrbahn gibt unter dem
gewicht nach und genau so wollen es die
ingenieure
[Musik]
die brücke ist zwar aus stahl aber sehr
flexibel und elastisch
verformt sich wenn ein großes gewicht
auf ihr lastet und kommt dann wieder
zurück in den ausgangszustand
deshalb ist auch die fahrbahn nicht fest
auf den pfeilern verankert sondern wird
hauptsächlich von den seinen gehalten
ihre bewegungen kann man an den
stützpfeilern sehen hier gleitet die
fahrbahn auf schienen hin und her bis zu
einen meter fünfzig
[Musik]
und sein kollege messen den abstand zum
pfeiler ist er kleiner als einen
millimeter wird es kritisch alle vier
wochen machen sie die toleranz messungen
dafür nutzen sie unterschiedlich dicke
metallstäbe
auf dem zettel steht dass es beim
letzten mal 1,6 mm waren lasst uns sehen
ob sich etwas verändert hat im letzten
monat
[Musik]
der abstand ist gleich geblieben
ein gutes ergebnis für die panther die
halter kabel erfüllen ihre funktion wie
geplant
[Musik]
auch den seinen arbeiten sich die
elektrikerin war schon die us
unterdessen weiter hoch
[Musik]
die männer haben extra für den job eine
kletter ausbildung gemacht nach 35
minuten aufstieg erreichen sie die
spitze des pfeilers
wir haben strenge sicherheitsregeln wenn
es zum beispiel zu feucht ist oder
regnet können wir nicht aufsteigen weil
es einfach zu glücklich ist man könnte
auf dem kabel wegrutschen und sich trotz
sicherung verletzen werde und dass sie
ist nicht gerade die leichteste ort für
eine bergung wir müssen natürlich auch
die windgeschwindigkeit beobachten wie
kann sich hier schnell ändern
über einen steg gelangen die beiden auf
die andere seite hier wartet die heutige
aufgabe die signallampe am höchsten
punkt der brücke muss regelmäßig
inspiziert werden
die nähe zum flughafen macht diese
arbeit so wichtig elvers checkt ob die
bürger noch in ordnung ist oder schon
ausgetauscht werden muss ausfallen darf
sie nie die ponte liegt unterhalb der
einflugschneise deshalb setzt man auf
früherkennung
ich mag meine arbeit mit ton zu arbeiten
das ist das was ich kann was ich mache
seit dem ich 13 jahre alt bin
jetzt bin ich 62 ich mache das also
schon lange und dann noch an so einem
ort mit diesem ausblick
mein arbeitstag auf der brücke des
fünfundzwanzigster april geht zu ende
sie ist eine der wenigen hängebrücken
dieser größenordnung die auch für
schwere schienenfahrzeuge ausgelegt sind
[Musik]
ein echtes lasten tier unter den
eisenbahnbrücken
jetzt geht es hoch hinaus in die
zerklüftete berglandschaft montenegros
[Musik]
dort steht dass malaria viadukt
die höchste eisenbahnbrücke
europas
sie liegt 198 meter über der talsohle
nach vier jahren bauzeit wird sie 1976
fertiggestellte
20 kilometer nördlich der hauptstadt
podgorica gelegen führt das viadukt über
den fluss male rijeka
der bau des viadukts gilt bis heute als
eines der waghalsigsten brückenprojekt
europas
und auch seiner wartung ist kein
kinderspiel
[Musik]
seit über 40 jahren ermöglicht die
eingleisige brücke den bahnverkehr
zwischen serbien und montenegro
allerdings ist sie auch seit über 40
jahren nicht mehr restauriert worden
dabei donnern mehrmals täglich tonnen
schwere züge über den stahlkoloss
[Musik]
eine sperrung der brücke würde eine der
wichtigsten eisenbahn routen im
ehemaligen jugoslawien lahmlegen eine
umfassende restaurierung ist also nicht
drin trotzdem wird die brücke so gut es
geht in stand gehalten
sercan lackovic und drago manager
gehören zum wartungsteam und fahren
jeden tag von podgorica raus zur brücke
[Musik]
die bahn strecke schlängelt sich
eindrucksvoll durch die berge
montenegros
das gelände ist sehr schwierig im sommer
fallen immer wieder steine auf die
gleise
hier herrschen starke winde und im
winter liegt so viel schnee dass er die
brücke und die gleise beschädigen können
vor ein paar jahren hat eine lawine den
zugverkehr komplett lahmgelegt
aus dem zug heraus hält das team schon
mal ausschau nach möglichen schäden für
den wartungs chef mit deniz ist es jeden
tag aufs neue ein besonderer moment wenn
er sich mit seinem triebwagen dem
viadukten ehrt
jedes mal wenn ich über die brücke
fahren und das tal sehe dann ist das wie
ein adrenalinstoß
kein wunder die knapp 500 meter lange
stahlkonstruktion liegt am tiefsten
punkt des tals rund 200 meter hoch
darunter eine tiefe schlucht und
unwegsames gelände
das wartungsteam kontrolliert die
strecke aufmerksam
durch die hitze kann sich im sommer der
stahl verziehen doch heute sieht somit
ist aus dem zug heraus alles okay aus
als nächstes inspizieren media und seine
kollegen sämtliche teile der brücke aus
der nähe
ich muss nicht nur die gleise
kontrollieren sondern auch die brücke
und das wartungs gerüst zum beispiel auf
rost mit dem gerüst kann man die
leitungen an der brücke reparieren
deswegen muss es immer einsatzbereit
sein
rost ist der ärgste feind der
eisenbahnbrücke überall frisst er sich
durch die mehr als drei millionen
kilogramm stahl die hier verbaut sind
wäre view witsch ist bauingenieur in sie
sammelt alle daten die wichtig sind für
die instandhaltung des viadukts die
extremen temperaturschwankungen hier in
der schlucht machen der brücke besonders
zu schaffen
42 grad bei extremer hitze denen sich
die gleise oft um mehrere zentimeter aus
das messen der schienen temperatur ist
sehr wichtig weil sie mit dem wechsel
der jahreszeiten stark schwankt
im winter sind es minus 20 grad und im
sommer manchmal sogar 55 grad plus
deshalb prüfen wir ob alles richtig
funktioniert und die schienen gerade
bleiben
in der unwegsamen berglandschaft ist der
brückenbau besonders aufwendig
die beiden hauptpfeiler stehen auf
steilen abhängen
damit sie trotzdem standfest sind muss
ein teil des brüchigen gesteins
abgetragen werden für jedes fundament
kommen anschließend 8000 kubikmeter
beton zum einsatz
berlin co sie ist der geologische leiter
beim bau mir damals gerade mal 25 jahren
verantwortet er sämtliche sprengungen
wir haben 15 meter lange tunnel in den
fels gebohrt in tv
die haben wir tonnen von
plastiksprengstoff eingebracht
dann haben wir die tunnel von außen
verschlossen
ferngezündet und boom
der ganze berg ist für eine sekunde
abgehoben und wieder runtergebracht wie
ein kleines erdbeben
1969 beginnt der eigentliche bau mit
hilfe von zwei riesigen kränen montieren
die arbeiter fachwerk kostenträger auf
den vier beton pylonen insgesamt rund
3000 tonnen stahl
250 menschen arbeiten an der brücke zwei
von ihnen kommen dabei ums leben
der nordwind war damals so stark dass
wir uns während der arbeiten an den
händen hätten und eine menschliche kette
gebildet haben
damit keiner von der brücke fällt
auch wenn nur zwölf züge pro tag die
eingleisige strecke passieren die brücke
darf keine sicherheitsmängel haben
wäre wohl witsch erfasst deshalb alle
kritischen daten
die messungen erfolgen mit einer
altbewährten technik mit hilfe eines
lots dessen gewicht hängt vom feiner
kopf herab und zeigt auf eine skala am
boden des pfeilers in regelmäßigen
abständen ließ die geologin dort ab ob
und wie stark sich pfeiler und fundament
bewegen
[Musik]
das viadukt gehört zu den bekanntesten
wahrzeichen des landes
viele im wartungsteam sind stolz es
instand zu halten
[Musik]
das erste mal habe ich in der
mittelschule von der brücke gehört
damals habe ich es nicht für möglich
gehalten aber mein lebenstraum war es
auf dem maler rijeka viadukt zu arbeiten
bis eines tages die große restaurierung
ansteht überprüft forschungschef
medenica die brücke täglich auf
korrosionsschäden
dazu gehören auch der blick von oben die
funktionskontrolle des wartungs wagens
für heute ist der check beendet alles
sieht gut aus die brücke ist
betriebsfähig
[Musik]
es ist alles in ordnung die brücke ist
so geplant worden dass sie besonders
stark und robust ist
alle pfeiler und fachwerk träger sind
stabil sie können die brücke noch sehr
lange tragen
[Musik]
für heute ist der job erledigt der
zugverkehr auf der höchsten
eisenbahnbrücke europas keine
reibungslos weiterlaufen
[Musik]
ingenieure entwickeln immer größere und
schnellere züge deshalb müssen neue
eisenbahnbrücken an die wachsenden
anforderungen angepasst werden
auch in deutschland schauplatz die ic
strecke zwischen nürnberg und erfurt die
neue schnellfahrstrecke soll den
zugverkehr in der region beschleunigen
20 millionen euro werden investiert um
die grümpen talbrücke mit ihrer bogen
spannweite von 270 metern zu bauen die
gruppen talbrücke liegt in südthüringen
sie ist eine von 40 talbrücken in dem
groß angelegten verkehrsprojekt das ziel
eine modelleisenbahn
hochgeschwindigkeits achse zwischen
berlin und münchen
dafür verlegen 9000 arbeiter über 2000
kilometer schienen
über die gruppen talbrücke sollen züge
mit über 300 kilometern pro stunde
hinweg dollar
heute steht eine der letzten
inspektionen vor der inbetriebnahme an
für den bau des bogens wurden hilfsweise
eingesetzt nach der fertigstellung
wurden sie gesprengt hat die brücke
dadurch schaden genommen
der ingenieur sebastian zopf und seine
kollegen nehmen die brücke unter die
lupe
sie sollen klären ob es mängel im
bauwerk gibt die die inbetriebnahme
gefährden können
[Musik]
die männer stehen auf einer speziellen
arbeitsbühne mit der sie direkt unter
den bogen scheitel fahren sie prüfen ob
der bogen seit der fertigstellung 2010
ermüdungserscheinungen aufweist
schauen wir noch mal drauf ob sich
irgendwelche risse ergeben haben last
umlagerungen ergeben haben schließlich
sollen ja herr züge mit 300 km/h mal
drüber fahren
auch die schweren baustellenfahrzeuge
die oben auf der brücke arbeiten können
schäden verursachen aber
den wirklich schon aus dieser entfernung
nicht mehr sehen deswegen müssen wir
handeln
hand nahe bedeutet mit höchstens 50
zentimeter abstand und das bei einem
rund 1100 meter langen bauwerk vom turm
aus checkt ein ingenieur die seiten
freund des beton bogens auf risse und
veränderungen unten auf der
arbeitsplattform sucht sebastian zopf
nach schäden
er dokumentiert den mangel für die
bauleitung bisher haben zopf und sein
team nur wenige schäden entdeckt das
team hat offenbar ganze arbeit geleistet
bei der konstruktion des riesen bodens
projektleiter martin schnell hat hat den
bau begleitet
270 meter weit gespannten bogen war von
daher eine herausforderung
dass die baufirma ein bauverfahren
gewählt hatte was
für bogen tragwerke eher ungewöhnlich
war
der bogen entsteht abschnittsweise unter
einsatz von acht hilfs feilen und einer
sogenannten vorschub rüstung das
bewegliche leer gerüst wird an den
pfeilern hochgezogen es trägt die
schalung auf die der beton für den bogen
gegossen wird
als der bogen geschlossen ist werden die
hilfswelle gesprengt ein kritischer
moment in dem die gesamtlast auf den
bogen selbst übertragen
[Applaus]
die sprengung sorgt damals für aufsehen
es hatte sich eine kleine menschentraube
gebildet von auch von anwohnern die wird
im ort wohnen und dort standen alle ganz
aufgeregt ob denn die pfeiler nun auch
alle so in die richtung fallen wo sie
hinfallen sollten das ist ja dann doch
auch eine kunst des sprengmeisters das
dann so zu machen dass es auch in
richtung feld
insgesamt 100 kilogramm sprengstoff und
über 1000 bohrlöcher sind nötig um die
acht pfeiler zu sprengen
am ende geht alles gut doch haben die
sprengung und die sogenannte last
umladung spuren am boden hinterlassen
haben und das ist eigentlich dadurch
dass sie eine last umlagerung
stattgefunden hat durch die hilfsstützen
die hier alle waren die dann
weggesprengt worden und dann kamen die
leistung lagen direkt in den bogen man
könnte hier eigentlich nämlich mal
seiten risse erwarten jetzt nix da
dem wartungsteam darf keine
unregelmäßigkeit entgehen die brücke ist
so konzipiert dass sie im betrieb extrem
wartungsarm ist die nächste inspektion
steht erst wieder in sechs jahren an und
dann das
und sagen dann auch dass diese stellen
saniert werden müssen wenn stahl rostet
dehnt sich der rost eben aus und durch
die ausdehnung drückt der praktisch von
innen gegen den beton und sorgt dafür
dass dann teile des betons wegbrechen
die rost stelle ist ein meter 20 lang
das ist mehr als nur eine lappalie der
schaden muss schnell behoben werden
bevor sich der rost ausbreiten kann doch
noch wichtiger ist die frage wo die
feuchtigkeit herkommt die zur korrosion
geführt hat
der bogen ist innen hohlen und komplett
begehbar
[Musik]
über eine luke gelangt man ins innere
kopf vermutet dass von irgendwoher
wasser eindringt der rost fleck spricht
dafür
[Musik]
hier rein verirrt sich nur selten jemand
entwarnung das innere des bogens ist
trocken
der rest muss eine andere ursache haben
der jurist ist wichtig alle möglichen
schadens quellen zu prüfen
mit frost und allem drum und dran
vollgelaufen ist dann ist das natürlich
sehr schädigend
heute ist aber alles in ordnung die
grünenthal brücke hat die inspektion mit
bravour bestanden eine inbetriebnahme
steht nichts im weg als teil der neuen
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke wird sie
dazu beitragen den eisenbahnverkehr in
deutschland zu modernisieren
[Musik]